many we still have as I mentioned
earlier serious civil rights problems in
this country in terms of the unfair
treatment and status of our black and
Hispanic and other citizens in addition
to that we still they are talking about
medical care they are talking about
education at least in very broad terms
and we certainly have a long way to go
before our schools can compete with the
education being received all over the
world in math science and other subjects
on the foreign policy front we're saying
almost nothing about Pakistan which I
think may be the next great danger point
in the world at least to the values that
we hold dear we're saying almost nothing
about the logical balanced solutions to
the continuing conflict in the Middle
East because American politicians are
afraid to address a balanced solution in
the Middle East so there are good many
subjects that I might add in 1960 the
candidates at least John F Kennedy
talked about real issues and real
proposals it was in the nineteen sixty
campaign that he advanced the Peace
Corps idea is in the nineteen sixty
campaign that he advanced the Alliance
for Progress with Latin America it was
in the nineteen sixty campaign that he
proposed an arms control and disarmament
see that he talked about having more
blacks in the Foreign Service and isn't
so on he was not afraid to talk about
very important issues in SEPs and
indocin politics